der traum der unsterblichkeit für viele
das ziel schlechthin aber ist es nicht
viel wichtiger die lebenszeit die man
hat gesund zu leben
dabei spielen nicht nur die ernährung
und bewegung eine entscheidende rolle
die wissenschaft hat noch mehr tipps und
tricks für eine möglichst gesunde
lebensweise klicksafe user gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende themen aus
der wissenschaft abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los gehen herzlich willkommen
pixum gibt es übrigens auch als podcast
die links dazu sind in der video
beschreibung und hier und ami man ist
was man isst auch wenn dieser satz nach
dem motto einer oma klingt ist dann doch
tatsächlich viel wahres dran in diesem
zusammenhang gibt es viele mögliche
stellschrauben um dem eigenen körper
etwas gutes zu tun fangen wir mit dem
thema zucker an der mittlerweile ja
wirklich überall drin steckt im fastfood
in getränken und natürlich auch in
süßigkeiten
wenn wir zu viel davon essen ist das
ungesund denn dann erhöht sich
zahlreichen studien zufolge nicht nur
das risiko für übergewicht sondern auch
für diabetes herz kreislauf erkrankungen
und zudem auch für karies dabei
schmecken schokolade cola und so weiter
einfach zu gut und manchmal scheint es
außerdem auch so als würde zucker
glücklich machen die rede ist vom
sogenannten zucker hoch zucker also als
glücklich machen ein mythos oder steckt
darin auch ein fünkchen wahrheit genau
das hat jetzt ein britisches
forschungsteam genauer unter die lupe
genommen bis dahin wurde sowohl von
negativen als auch von positiven
effekten des zuckers berichten die
fachleute analysierten also 31
untersuchung mit knapp 1300 probandinnen
und probanden alle hatten sich damit
befasst wie sich der konsum von zucker
auf die stimmung auswirkt das ergebnis
der britischen meta studie ist eindeutig
es handelt sich um einen weit
verbreiteten irrglauben dass zucker uns
glücklich machen kann dazu der forscher
konstantinos man tanzes der an der
studie beteiligt war
die idee dass zucker die stimmung heben
kann ist so verbreitet dass menschen auf
der ganzen welt zuckerhaltige getränke
trinken und
des next verzehren um schnell ihre laune
zu verbessern aufmerksamer zu werden
oder ihre müdigkeit zu bekämpfen
unsere ergebnisse zeigen jedoch dass
solche annahmen jeder grundlage
entbehren wenn überhaupt dann sorgt der
zucker dafür dass wir uns schlechter
fühlen
die analyse der zahlreichen untersuchung
offenbarte den fachleuten also dass
zucker keinen positiven einfluss auf
unsere emotionen hat ganz im gegenteil
diejenigen teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer die zucker zu sich nahm
fühlten sich im durchschnitt mutter und
unaufmerksamer als die probandinnen und
probanden die nur ein placebo bekamen
heißt also zuckerkonsum hat keinerlei
positive auswirkungen auf den
menschlichen körper
dabei ist das thema übergewicht in den
vergangenen jahren zum dauerbrenner
geworden nach angaben des robert koch
instituts sind zwei drittel der männer
und die hälfte der frauen in deutschland
übergewichtig ein viertel aller
erwachsenen sind sogar adipös also stark
übergewichtig und das widerspricht einem
gesunden lebensstil natürlich komplett
auf der webseite des
robert-koch-instituts es heißt es
übergewicht und adipositas sind mit
ursache für viele beschwerden und können
die entwicklung chronischer krankheiten
begünstigen
aufgrund der steigenden prävalenz und
den damit verbundenen folgeerkrankungen
entstehen beträchtliche kosten für das
gesundheits- und sozialsystem
übergewicht und adipositas sind daher
themen von hoher public health relevanz
im zug kommt übergewicht begünstigt auch
diabetes und auch hier sind die zahlen
der betroffenen in deutschland steigen
schätzung zufolge gibt es in deutschland
täglich fast 500 neuerkrankungen heißt
also im klartext um ein gesundes leben
zu führen sollten wir so weit wie
möglich auf zucker verzichten doch dass
es natürlich viel leichter gesagt als
getan denn zucker scheint eine süchtig
machende wirkung zu haben
in der wissenschaft gibt es zum thema
zuckersucht noch keine eindeutigen
ergebnisse gibt es sie überhaupt
jedenfalls gibt es viele kleine dinge
die einem dabei helfen können auf zucker
zu verzichten und so langfristig das
verlangen nach süßem zu verringern
bei instagram beispielsweise gibt es
viele profile die sich mit dem thema
zuckerfrei beschäftigen
fest steht jedenfalls wenn man sich
gedanken zu einem gesunden lebensstil
macht kommt man um die großen
ernährungsfragen nicht drum herum
brauchen der fleisch um uns gesund zu
ernähren oder sollten wir sogar vom
fleischkonsum abstand nehmen fest steht
immer mehr menschen verzichten auf
fleisch und tierische produkte bis zu 10
der deutschen ernähren sich umfragen
zufolge vegetarisch oder vegan
denn das blatt hat sich gewendet
fleischpreis essen gilt mittlerweile als
gesund eine untersuchung aus diesem
sommer 2020 zeigt dass das körpergewicht
unter body mass index von
vegetarierinnen und vegetariern im
schnitt geringer ist als das vom fleisch
essen und essen die fachleute des
max-planck-instituts für kognitions- und
neurowissenschaften befragten dafür
knapp 9000 menschen über drei jahre
hinweg zu ihrer ernährung außerdem wurde
auch der bmi ermittelt also der body
mass index und es wurden tests zur
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen durchgeführt
fachleute sind sich heutzutage sicher
dass eine vollwertige vegetarische oder
vegane ernährungsweise das risiko für
viele verschiedene krankheiten
verringern kann
zwei beispiele dazu zum einen kann eine
vegane ernährung die beschwerden bei
rheumatoider arthritis verbessern zum
anderen ist auch das erkrankungsrisiko
für diabetes typ 2 früher auch
altersdiabetes genannt verringert aber
auch das risiko an den so genannten
volkskrankheiten wie herzerkrankungen
übergewicht zu erkranken ist sehr viel
kleiner als bei menschen die viel und
häufig fleisch und wurst essen es gibt
schätzungen nach denen im
gesundheitswesen rund 900 milliarden
euro weltweit eingespart werden könnten
wenn sich alle menschen vegan ernähren
würden und dazu kommt wenn wir mehr obst
und gemüse essen würden und dafür
deutlich weniger fleisch könnten
menschenleben gerettet werden laut einer
studie eines forschungsteams aus oxford
könnten bis zum jahr 2050 8 millionen
menschen vor dem frühzeitigen tod
bewahrt werden das ist schon eine
beeindruckende zahlen
nach offiziellen empfehlungen wie
beispielsweise lauter academy of
nutrition and tactics ist eine
vegetarische ernährung für alle lebens-
und altersphasen geeignet in dieser
organisation haben sich rund 70.000
medizinische fachleute und andere
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zusammen getan
es ist die position der academy of
nutrition and ethics das gut geplante
vegetarische ernährungsform inklusive
streng vegetarische oder vegane
ernährungsform gesund
der stoff technisch angemessen sind
sowie gesundheitsvorteile bezüglich der
prävention und behandlung von gewissen
gesundheitszustände haben können und
auch die beispiele vieler erfolgreicher
profi sportler zeigen dass sich
körperliche höchstleistung und eine
vegane ernährung keineswegs ausschließen
mit dabei unter anderem formel 1
weltmeister lewis hamilton wimbledon
sieger novak djokovic
basketball-superstar dirk nowitzki oder
weltklassefußballer lionel messi alle
ernähren sich bevorzugt vegan wichtig
dabei sich gut über diese ernährungsform
zu informieren und so mögliche
mangelerscheinungen direkt von
vornherein ausschließen
neben der ernährung ist natürlich aber
auch die bewegung wichtig für eine
gesunde lebensweise sport kann herz
kreislauf erkrankungen und übergewicht
vorbeugen wer sport macht verlängert
sein leben aktuelle studien zeigen dass
regelmäßiges training sogar noch
gesünder ist als man bislang dachte denn
abgesehen davon dass sport nicht nur
einfluss auf unsere muskeln die knochen
und das herz hat macht es auch etwas mit
unserem gehirn beim sport beeinflussen
sich unsere organe gegenseitig das herz
muss kräftig pumpen und einem
herzinfarkt wird vorgebeugt
untersuchungen haben zudem offenbart
dass auch das risiko für schlaganfälle
durch regelmäßigen sport massiv abnimmt
das coole daran ist dass sich schon nach
wenigen wochen training positive effekte
zeigen
man kommt nicht so schnell aus der puste
und der gesamte körper profitiert
fachleute halten vor allem
ausdauertraining wie etwa auf dem
crosstrainer als besonders wichtig und
so gibt es mittlerweile sogar ärztinnen
und ärzte die sport als
präventionsmaßnahme auf rezept
verschreiben um von den gesundheits
effekten von sport profitieren reichen
pro woche etwa zweieinhalb stunden
moderate bewegung aus eine aktuelle
studie aus diesem sommer hat jetzt
offenbart dass sport sogar einen
doppelten effekt mit sich bringt demnach
macht krafttraining nicht nur unsere
muskeln stärker sondern wirkt auch auf
unsere nerven und das gehirn und das
schon nach wenigen tagen des trainings
der aktuellen untersuchung zufolge
werden schon dann die signalleitungen in
speziellen bahnen des rückenmarks und im
motorischen zentrum des gehirns
verstärkt heißt also das gehirn wird
durch die bewegung besser durchblutet
hinzu kommt dass die muskeln einen
botenstoff ausschütten der die
neubildung von nervenzellen anregte das
könnte nach ansicht des forschungsteams
möglicherweise sogar gegen alzheimer
wirken für das experiment ließen die
britischen fachleute affen einen ihre
arme mit einer art handte trainieren
dabei wurde analysiert wie stark die
nervensignale von motorischen kortex des
gehirns über das rückenmark zu den arm
muskeln geleitet wurden in den ersten
wochen des krafttrainings konnten die
fachleute keinerlei veränderungen an den
muskeln registrieren dafür aber an den
nervenbahnen zum einen verstärkten sich
die sogenannten extra pyramidal 'nen
signale die dafür zuständig sind kleinen
hirnstamm hirn und rückenmark zu
verbinden
diese extra pyramiden signale steuern
also die halte muskulatur und die
gröberen kraft aufwendigen muskel
aktionen diese verstärkten sich durch
das krafttraining bereits in der ersten
zeit also messbar ebenso die reaktion
des steuer zentrums im motorischen
kortex die britischen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
schließen aus diesen ergebnissen dass
die zunehmende kraft durch das training
nicht nur auf die muskeln zurückzuführen
ist stattdessen führt auch die erhöhte
neuronale signale stärke dazu dass sich
die muskeln mehr anstrengen heißt also
im klartext krafttraining stärkt nicht
nur unsere muskeln sondern auch unsere
nerven doch wir müssen nicht ständig
kasse sportprogramme durchziehen um
gesund zu bleiben ist beim krafttraining
übrigens auch gefährlich viel wichtiger
wäre es dass häufiges sitzen zu
minimieren besonders die lange
schreibtischarbeit ist ungesund manche
fachleute bezeichnen das sitzen sogar
schon als das neue rauchen demnach kann
langes ununterbrochenes sitzen nicht nur
das risiko für
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen diabetes und
krebs erhöhen sondern sogar zu einem
früheren tod führen forschungsteams
weltweit haben in studien offenbart dass
diese negativen effekte des sitzens
nicht einmal durch den sport nach der
arbeit ausgeglichen werden können die
fachleute empfehlen stattdessen ein
regelmäßiges und kurzes unterbrechen der
sitz phasen eine pause vom sitzen also
in der man sich im besten fall bewegt
und herum zappelt doch auch unser gehirn
und unser geist braucht pausen das ist
für eine gesunde lebensweise keinesfalls
zu unterschätzen
entspannung ist also super wichtig um
wieder kraft und energie für den alltag
zu bekommen davon ist mittlerweile auch
die wissenschaft überzeugt denn
ansonsten kann der menschliche körper
die stresshormone nicht komplett abbauen
wenn wir
nicht regelmäßige entspannungsphasen
können kann der körper sich nicht
regenerieren untersuchungen offenbaren
dass dauerhafter stress äußerst ungesund
sind es drohen diabetes depressionen und
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen der stadt
einmal meditiert hat oder yoga macht
kann das bestätigen was auch die
forschung herausgefunden hat entspannung
funktioniert besonders gut mit hilfe des
atems wenn wir langsam und tief atmen
werden die muskeln schlaf der blutdruck
sinkt genauso wie die herzfrequenz ganz
vorne mit dabei der parasympathikus
fachleute meinen damit den beruhigenden
teil des nervensystems in studien haben
sich wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vor allem mit yoga und
meditation beschäftigt beispielsweise
konnte eine metastudie für die insgesamt
15 studien mit rund 1700 probanden
genauer analysiert wurden herausfinden
dass die entspannende wirkung von yoga
geburtsschmerzen lindern kann auch
regelmäßige meditation kann uns gut
dabei unterstützen gesund zu leben
befragungen haben ergeben dass sich
menschen nach einer meditation deutlich
wacher und dafür weniger gestresst
fühlen doch nicht nur meditationen
schaffen wohl auch die aufmerksamkeit
ein britischer hirnforscher konnte in
einer untersuchung zeigen dass seine
probanden probanden nach der mediation
besser versteckte zahlen auf einem
bildschirm erkennen als vorher
erstaunlich auch das ergebnis einer
weiteren studie hier fanden
forscherinnen und forscher heraus dass
menschen die regelmäßig meditieren
gefühle besser verarbeiten können
möglicherweise ist das darauf
zurückzuführen dass beim meditieren neue
verknüpfungen in bestimmten hirnarealen
entstehen was darf ich trinken
mineralwasser eiszeit wasser oder
leitungswasser welches wasser ist gesund
anklicken anschauen und diesen kanal
abonnieren clixoom science in future bis
dann bleibt dran